vrooom vrooom started off we have this
goober ass named Gayle King so if you
aren't aware Gayle King was on CBS doing
an interview about Kobe Bryant a clip
was posted online
basically Gayle went about you know
asking Leslie what she thought about
them
Leslie countered by saying listen I he
that's not how I know him I know him to
be a very good innocent person and then
Gil kept pressing her and when people
saw the clip it went viral everyone got
mad all right i watch the clip I
understand why people got mad there's no
surprise to me and I mean people are mad
baby mad man
big man I'd answer her pressing that was
that doesn't really show me that she had
an agenda because I already tell you you
asked me a question I already tell you
no it's not like that yeah but really
it's really what do you think about that
no it's really not like that yeah but
come on
no it's not like that yeah but you
wouldn't know you don't care about it at
this point when someone is acting like
that it doesn't matter right what I'm
gonna answer all right you're still on
your you still on your track it's a
dictionary you're not trying to find the
truth you're trying to fit your
narrative and that's what really
bothered me so Dale came out after all
the backlash and she said yo I did that
with the full length wasn't as bad if
you guys had seen it you would
understand I showed it to Leslie she was
fine with it like they did they put out
that short clip unbeknownst to me no I
watched both the short and the long one
the short one is extremely insulting the
long one is still insulting she didn't
give the full context so even in the
entirety of the clip when you watch the
full interview she still doesn't give
the full context of the court case if
you want to bring up that fine bring up
the whole context don't cherry pick what
you want to pay the image that you want
because if you do don't be mad if other
people who know that most of the context
get mad at you don't be surprised you
omitted details you are lying
so don't be mad when someone gets mad
about your lives jail has been saying
really weird stuff reason why this
troubles me so much is that if men are
doing the right thing and they're
behaving appropriately they don't have
to worry about any of this they don't
have to worry about being accused how a
black woman could say this is
unbelievable to me don't you know our
history both them John
chi'lan
apartment city new song Emmett Till
Betty Newsom Tatiana Jefferson the BTC
new zone the central part 1 2 3 4 5 5 5
and so Gil came afterward and said no
CBS is the one who put up the short one
but I'm like listen brah of course you
work for them and there's no doubt that
he put why did you think they put you
forth to do the interview in the purse
because you're white poseable no because
she's a black woman who do they always
get whenever it comes to black
entertainment our athletes who do they
get to do most of those interviews you
know what it is it's my quota jury
winner owner being in the business when
her owner in the club doesn't like black
people and has a quota on black people
and trust me it does happen what they do
is that they don't put the white bouncer
in front coz now the whole thing is
shifty they put the black bouncer in
front to tell the people ya know we
don't we don't accept some poor so you
cannot accuse them you cannot accuse the
network of racism if they would have put
a black host they're doing that
automatically it would have been like
ISM and this and that but they put black
woman just so that it you can't you
can't call it it is the Blythe Inc CBS
used her a hundred percent but here's my
thing is like you benefited from them
using you you made millions of dollars
you played into the fact that they were
gonna use your blackness as a means to
be able to take down the legacy of black
people you can't let them use you if you
don't buy into some degree it's a
mutually beneficial relationship even if
I recognized that they were trash for
putting up that short clip and it's no
surprise that they did because they just
want clicks or you benefit it every
media company right now is thirsting for
clicks so when they put up that short
clip without context I'm like how does a
journalistic company do something like
that but they're well aware of what
they're doing they want to create
controversy because any other day it
creates traffic so if you guys really
want to hurt them boycott CBS that's
pretty much it
that's the only way these people are
gonna learn is when their money's
affected I'm done all moaning I'm done
accusing people all i'ma say is I'm done
with y'all because that's how y'all move
and you
don't get me that's what don't don't
repost the clips don't cuz that's what
they want they actually want it doesn't
matter if you repost the clip and you
trash it or you repost the clip and you
praise it it does not matter at the end
of the day you repost to that and you
created a clique Oprah came to gales
defense because they're best friends and
you already know what they say what I
mean if you're gonna shuck and jive
might as well do it as a duo I think the
last 24 hours for your best friend have
been pretty difficult after that
interview with Lisa Leslie about Kobe
and I just wondered just how she's doing
and it's not doing well may I say she is
not she is not doing well and has to now
travel with security and she's feeling
very much attacked how do you think Kobe
Bryant's family feels exactly you see
how Oprah was mad about the fact that
people were attacking her Gayle King for
valid reasons
imagine how mad people get when you
attack someone they love for invalid
reasons if you want sympathy learn to
sympathize if you want to be treated
like a human being
learn to treat others like a human being
cut the man is dead I don't know about
your community but where I'm from that
means something you let the dead rest
you don't understand spit on it and this
man hasn't even been buried yet and
you're already throwing dirt on his name
you guys want to put dirt on a man who
hasn't even been buried in dirt think
about that so how do you want me to
sympathize very much attacked you know
Cosby is texting from tweeting from jail
hey my man Cosby trying to get a licking
- he'd be like hey get some of this
chocolate pudding you the bobbidi boo
you did
[Laughter]
you know I like this dolls in adamant
much like Bill Cosby's favorite people
oh I don't know how people are surprised
by Gayle King or Oprah throwing sorry no
Pro throwing black men under the bus
it's what they do so what they've been
doing Oprah has been doing this since
like the 80s and the 90s what what she's
done to hip-hop artists regularly you
know you saw what she did to MJ right
you saw if she's trying to do to Russell
Simmons you saw what she she got on with
Bill Cosby like she has no problem but
then you ask these same ladies who take
pictures with hawaiians teen all this
stuff and they're very quiet when Oprah
on her own show had that guy from Brazil
who's now being kid you know accused by
a thousand women for what he's done and
she's never come out against that I'm
just like how come y'all so comfortable
saying this stuff about black dudes but
when it comes to your people from other
communities you guys are quiet it is
what they do and what you have to
understand is not because black people
make it to a point of privilege and
power that they're necessarily going to
look out for black communities they
don't because sometimes when people get
to a certain financial level they
identify more with their financial
status then they do the communities from
which they came from it's not surprising
to me so me
I see more I see Oprah more as a rich
woman then I do see her as a black woman
if at all no this is what I think about
Oprah this is a no-brainer ah boy
[Music]
you know what the thing is really
unfortunate because like she was it's
crazy when I was growing up when my aunt
was a god hmm she was always watching
Oprah interesting topics and stuff like
that like she was when you're desperate
for a car but the thing that happened is
not just started and you know it is
probably gonna sound like I'm repeating
myself yes stop putting people on
pedestals are not all good or
necessarily all bad yes I said that and
that's the things when we have someone
that is on a pedestal like that they're
not there's some flaws to that and some
other flaws can be a detriment to your
culture and to your people and that's
what it is right now yeah well what do
you say to people who say we're putting
Kobe on a pedestal we're not well not
cuz we chart the thing that happened
with Kobe okay we're not saying that
he's an angel now he is but we're not
saying that we're not saying that he was
we're not saying that he was all good or
all bad it's not everybody it's not
pudding it's not that she cannot bash it
is it though is it North because she's
my thing right
right I always say believe the facts and
evidence yes these women are coming from
the perspective that believe women but
just today we have another story about
Amber Heard and we have recordings of
her saying who's going to believe that a
man was victimized absolutely so my
thing is like the evidence doesn't
corroborate the woman's story against
Kobe even though society refuses to
believe men why am I gonna give her the
credence if she has no evidence because
we already know for a fact that women do
like a lot I don't know why everyone's
coming out like we were pretending like
women or some kind of perfect gender no
you know why too so I'm throwing these
actually we don't lie
nobody would in a situation like this
lie about yes for millions of dollars
nobody would nobody nobody we know
millions don't know how you know if you
find a million
dollars in the bag you wouldn't lie no
problem I'll be honest with you got
another song no anything
Timbaland produced I know so carrying on
some people know him for Justin
Timberlake I know I know that song
because of Timbaland there's no there is
no Justin Timberlake without Timbaland
or The Neptunes no and it was not mad no
it was the rest of it hot garbage Oh
after they left it okay we all know
toward the 20/20 experience [ __ ] are
you blind
what are you talking about because that
was garbage okay look at you see what
you do to me
turn it up